Is there music?
I don't think so.
Sorry if you can hear, um, my computer.
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
Actually, can it- oh.
Okay, it is capturing on OBS.
Hello, ladies and gentlemen.
Ghouls and Goyles.
Welcome to the maid cafe and girlfriend rental location.
Welcome to the maid cafe and girlfriend location.
This is all that I could rent out on such last minute notice.
I am very sorry.
It's the 3D streaming.
It's not.
It's VR chat.
It's different.
If it's 3D stream, don't you think I would make like a bigger deal about it?
Also, um, for those who, uh, if you don't realize- if you didn't know, um, I had some issues with my- with my VR controllers.
They are currently plugged up right now.
So my limit- my movements are a little- my limits are limited.
My movements are limited.
Um, oh gosh.
And I have a...
I have, uh, what's the words?
A rental mint push-push!
I am insane!
No!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, real.
I can't tell if I'm backwards or not.
Why?
Hold on.
Okay, maybe- is it backwards for you guys?
No.
Okay, good.
Okay, there's no music in here.
I don't think.
There's no music here.
So, uh, here I come, everybody.
To the stage!
The one!
The only!
Bird!
Hey, guys.
I just flew in here and my- I'm sinking through the floor, apparently.
Oh gosh.
Uh, boy, are my arms tired.
Hello.
Um, yeah, I'm a little purple.
What about it, huh?
I'm a little purple.
And my arms aren't- are tired because my hands are like this because I'm a ghost!
Hello, welcome to, um, why am I sinking through the floor?
Oh god.
Oh no!
Oh god, now I'm sinking through- oh wait, those are my legs.
You can see them.
I was thinking I was gonna do a bit where I was actually sinking through the floor, but...
You guys just completely ruined it.
You guys just completely...
Completely ruined it.
Why is this mic so low?
And huge!
Hello.
Um...
Oh my god, even I have to bend down.
Hello.
Welcome to the maid cafe and girlfriend rental.
You guys, I think I'm a little afraid of this place because, uh...
Let me show you.
Also, if you can hear- if you can hear...
VR chat noises, no you cannot.
Hold on.
Hello.
Hi.
Gosh, I'm Bustin' already?
But that's okay!
Bustin' makes me feel good.
And you too.
Apparently.
Yeah!
Do you guys like the low-poly model?
I saw that Scuff Word made it, and I was like...
I wanna- I wanna use it.
It was- it's so cute, right?
Hold on.
Let me get out of- I'm pretty purple.
Oh.
I'm... pretty...
I'm pretty purple, though.
You can see...
Me in my dress.
Na-na-na-na-na-na.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
And my legs.
My legs.
My... body.
And such.
Yes.
And my arms.
Are like this, cause I'm a ghost.
The kicks.
Sorry.
My...
It's- it's still attached to a cord.
Oh.
Ah!
Guys, let me show you why I think I'm afraid of this place.
Where are you?
Oh.
Hold on.
One second.
Okay.
Can I show you guys?
I'm turning you around.
Sorry for my shaky hands.
Look at this beautiful...
Place.
Look at- wow.
I don't think this is a maid cafe.
First of all.
But the paw print...
The paw print...
Seats are very cute.
I do like those.
Let us...
Let me show you...
The reason I'm afraid of this place, I think.
So, um...
Na-na-na.
There's a bar.
They have some snacks.
I can't read that.
But let me show you why.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I'm struggling to leave.
Oh my God.
No.
lalalalalalalala.
lalalalalalalalalalala.
I don't know if it's copyright and- So, why are there these rooms?
Rooms suite one.
Rooms suite two.
And rooms suite three.
It's not like...
It's a suite.
But like a...
Like a...
Oh.
It's suite.
Amai.
Oishii.
But...
Okay.
Let's go to the room suite one together.
Well, thank you.
I can't read it though right now.
This looks no good.
Why would you need a bed in a maid cafe?
This... this is so bad.
What is going on here?
You get tired?
No!
To rest?
In a maid cafe, there's only energy!
There's only energy!
There's only moe moe energy coming at you!
There should be no resting!
Snake, it's a furry room.
What are you talking about?
I'm going to explore.
I'm going... I'm going... I'm going... I'm going in.
The pictures on the walls make me even more scared!
What is going on in this picture?
And then... and then... and then... over there!
That one too!
Why are they kissing?
Does the room smell funny?
Yes.
Let's go to another place, okay?
I think this place is kind of scary.
Where should we go?
The world is our oyster.
We can... we can go to McDonald's!
It's trending right now.
Let's go to McDonald's, everybody.
Alright.
Let's go.
McDonald's.
Here we go!
Whoa...
Okay, luckily it loaded pretty quickly.
I'm kind of scared.
Oh, gosh.
What are we going to see?
What do you guys see right now?
Oh, you guys see McDonald's.
I don't see anything.
Oh, we're here!
We're here!
Where are you guys?
Hello?
Oh.
There you are.
Hello.
Oh.
There we go.
Okay.
Wow!
This actually looks so nice.
Looks like a real McDonald's.
There's even like a sign up there.
Can't really see it.
Up there.
It's like, serving smiles from the year 3000.
That's a little cool.
Oh, sorry.
See?
Take a picture of me in front of McDonald's sign!
What am I doing?
Okay.
La la.
La la la.
In front of the McDonald's.
Whoa.
McDonald's.
In front of the McDonald's.
Nice.
Um.
Minto cute.
Shut the hell up.
What's that over there?
GNC.
Verizon.
Subway.
GameStop?!
And there's a Best Buy right there!
This is the most real American I've ever...
Wait, is that an Olive Garden?
Why is there a...
Why is there a McDonald's when we can go to Olive...
Oh, there's Best Buy.
Olive Garden instead!
Let's go.
Endless breadsticks.
This is real America simulator I think, actually.
Whoa!
Italian kitchen!
Woo!
Oh, come on.
Uh, excuse me.
Let me in.
Let me in to Olive Garden!
Please!
Please, I need to go!
Please, let me in to Olive Garden!
Let me...
Let me in!
Let me in, please.
Let me in.
Just let me in.
Please.
Oh, no.
Oh, I know this is probably a little late, but how's the audio and stuff?
Hopefully I'm not blowing your ears out.
Audio's good?
Is it thumbs up?
Sorry that there's no BGM.
Maybe I should've...
Maybe I should've put my own BGM.
What happened to you?
I don't know!
I have no idea!
I couldn't tell you.
Okay.
Let's turn you around.
Back to McDonald's, everybody.
Let's go inside McDonald's, see what they've got.
Can we go to Waffle House perchance?
But also, I wanna actually look at this.
What is that over yonder?
Oh, we have a Walgreens?
Oh, it's a Starbucks!
Oh my goodness.
These are...
What?
With the McMirror.
Huh?
Oh!
Oh.
Ah!
It's me looking at you, looking at...
Me looking at you, looking at...
This is a mirror.
This is not me.
The McMirror.
So funny.
Okay.
Can I...
Oh!
Oh, I think I'm gonna throw up.
Oh, no, no, don't ride the McMirror without...
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, I'm gonna throw up.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, God, please, someone help me.
Get off.
Get off, please.
Oh, God, oh, God.
Please get me off of this thing!
How do I get off?
I'm pressing everything!
Oh god.
Oh...
Don't ride.
Don't...
Don't ride it.
Where are you guys actually?
I don't even know where... where am I?
Oh, there you are.
Nice landing.
Gotta work those VR... I was like going...
I had no control over it.
What are these guys?
Oh, sorry.
These guys right here.
I can also sit on them.
Oh no!
Please, god!
Not again!
Oh, please!
Oh god, I can't stand!
I can't stand!
Oh god.
Oh...
Okay.
Okay, it stopped.
I'm okay.
I can stand up.
Hold on.
How do I get off it?
Get me off, please!
Why can't I leave?
Oh...
Scary, scary place.
Get rotated.
There's also a slide.
I wonder if...
Try the yellow one.
Okay.
Wait, is it different?
Is it different?
The different kinds?
That's red.
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
Okay, it's not any different.
It's not any different.
I'm gonna do the slide though.
Will you guys watch me?
Watch me do the slide.
Okay.
I'm gonna put it kind of far so you can see the whole process.
Okay?
Okay.
Actually, I'm just gonna have it look at me.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Okay.
Watch me!
Watch me, mom!
Watch me go on the slide!
I gotta go on the slide.
Okay, mom?
Watch me go on the slide!
How do I get up?
Okay.
Can you see me?
Wait, you can't see me.
Hi, mom!
Here we go.
Oh, it says to sit on it.
Okay.
Wee!
Did you see me, mom?
Did you...
Did you see me?
Did you see me go on the...
Okay, hold on.
Go on the slide?
Right?
Oh!
Yep.
Gosh.
This is the place for kids to go.
This is the number one children's activity.
La criatura.
She's coughing up blood.
Nah.
I'm okay.
Coughing up ectoplasm.
Maybe a little bit.
Okay.
I'm okay.
There's also a drive-thru, but we don't have a car.
Unless there is a car there.
I think we should...
I think we should steal it.
I think we should steal the car.
Alright.
Follow me.
Oh.
Where is it?
There it is.
Oh.
No.
I'm going the wrong way.
Sorry.
I'm looking through what you guys are seeing.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
I'm gonna pretend...
I'm gonna pretend I like...
Broke my foot.
Okay.
And you're just gonna...
And then...
When they get out of the car to help me...
You...
You get in.
Okay?
As soon as I'm just like...
Oof.
Ouch.
My foot.
Okay?
I'm gonna make it really convincing.
Not like that.
Okay?
Like really, really...
Okay.
So...
You good?
You ready?
Don't chicken out on me, rookie.
Don't chicken out on me right now.
Are you good or are you good?
Come on.
That's what I thought.
And don't get distracted by the Best Buy either.
Okay?
Let's go.
Okay.
Excuse me.
I think I...
Oh...
Oh God.
What's happening to me actually?
I think I broke my foot.
Oh God.
It hurts.
What's happening to me?
Wait.
I said I would make it convincing but not like this.
Oh God.
I think I broke my foot.
What's happening?
Oh...
Can you please help me?
That's your key.
That's your cue.
Help!
Help, please!
Help me, please!
I think I broke my foot!
Oh, my body!
I think I broke my body!
Oh, what's happening?
Oh, god!
Oh, please, please!
Please, oh, please help me!
Get out the car!
That's your cue.
Please!
Please let me in!
Please help me!
Take me to a hospital!
I need to use your car!
Please!
I can't pay for the hospital!
Give me your four digits!
Give me your car digits and the three numbers on the back, please!
What are we supposed to do again?
You're supposed to get in the car.
Okay, you know what?
I'll do it.
It's undone!
Go, go, go!
Run!
Oh, my god!
It's the wrong type of vehicle!
I'm in this, I'm in this car, actually.
Wait.
How do I jump?
Oh, there we go.
No!
Hold on.
You guys are so far away.
Don't leave us to die!
Alright, come on.
You guys gotta use your, you guys gotta use your little leggies, okay?
Come on.
It's okay, we got another car.
We got one right here.
Oh, oh.
Oh, why am I still so shaky?
Are we okay?
Is everything okay?
I can't tell.
Futurama ship?
This one?
I don't know what it's gonna do to me, though, guys.
I'm kinda scared.
I don't know what it's gonna do to me.
Oh!
Woah!
Oh my god.
Wee!
Ah!
Oh my god.
I'm scaffolding!
We can go through the drive-thru now, everybody!
Woah!
I'm coming back!
Wait, something just happened.
Where did I go?
Oh!
Wait, I don't know.
What just happened?
Wait, where am I at?
I'm at Starbucks!
Wait, how did I get to Starbucks?
Wait, you cut.
Ah!
Um...
Sorry.
There were people there.
Is everybody okay?
I just jumped back home.
I jumped ship.
I didn't know what to do.
I just...
I'm sorry!
I didn't know what to do!
There were people there!
How am I supposed to talk?
Oh...
Everything's fine.
You know what?
We didn't even go inside.
We didn't even go inside to the McDonald's.
Oh man.
But...
I have a place that I really, really, really wanted to go.
Is it okay?
Is it okay if I go?
I saw this on...
I saw it on Twitter a couple months ago.
Maybe not even a couple months.
Maybe like a month ago...
And I was like...
That's...
When I do a VR chat stream, I must go there.
I must.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for all the donuts too, thank you!
Super chats and memberships, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
It's kind of hard to read a little bit, so...
But let me see.
LapperStyle says it's your birthday on Friday!
Happy early birthday!
Unfortunately I can't go to Off-Kai, but can you bring me back some chaotic energy when you come back?
YES!
Well, I'll be going from the con to Japan, so it might take a while.
Probably.
You know?
So...
ShadowMoses?
Close.
Not quite.
Wait, hold on.
Not quite, ShadowMoses.
Not quite.
No, no, no.
And Jago, thank you for the...
And...
Gifted, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
We're gonna go.
And we're gonna explore...
Probably.
Alright, give me a second to pull it up.
I haven't...
I only looked around it a little bit.
Uh...
Can you hear me typing, by the way?
The ping-pong, ping-pong-pong?
Hmm...
Ah, here.
Here we are.
Hmm...
Let's go!
The rising world.
You're in the void, yeah.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Sorry, there's a guy over there that scared me.
Look at him.
Wait, can you see him?
That.
That guy scared me.
I thought it was real.
Welcome to...
Arsenal Gear!
Yippee!
It's the big shell!
Yes, we're here in the big shell.
We're gonna go searching for bombs and...
whatever else is in here.
Whatever else our hearts desire.
I'm gonna... have it not look at me.
I'm gonna turn you guys around.
Oh, see him?
That's what I turned and looked at.
That's what I turned and saw.
I was like, I thought that was a real person.
But look how cool it is!
Welcome to Metal Gear, everybody.
You can access Arsenal Gear through Shell 1 Core B2 Hostage Room.
Okay.
Yup, totally.
Alright.
I guess I can walk through this.
No, I cannot.
I think I can...
jump up this.
No, I cannot.
Wait, how do I get around?
Huh?
How do I get through?
The vent?
Is it really gonna actually make me crawl?
Here...
Here I go.
Whoa!
Oh, I'm too big!
I'm too big!
Hold on.
Save EE this time.
Okay, don't look at my skirt, though.
Don't...
Don't look at my skirt.
Okay.
Wait...
Don't...
Don't look...
Don't do it!
Stop!
Okay, hold on.
I have to lay down.
I think...
Is it working?
Oh, I can't fit!
I can't...
I can't fit.
You guys, I can't fit.
Um...
We're looking away.
I don't wanna crawl.
Is there a way to crawl?
Oh...
Okay.
I don't think this is correct.
Unless...
Can I get low enough?
Can I get down low enough?
Can I get down low enough to fit?
Come on!
Go, Mint!
Go!
Can you get down low?
How low can you go?
Two!
Thank you!
How low can you go?
Can you get down low?
Okay.
I don't think that worked.
Hmm...
There's a...
There's a floss thing.
There's a floss emote, but I kinda wanna try flossing first.
Okay.
This is...
This is me actually trying to floss.
And then this is the real floss.
Oh!
Wait!
Help me!
I can't stop!
Oh!
Oh my god!
That was the real floss, everybody!
How do I get past here?
I'm actually so confused.
Okay.
This is...
Let me try going in without you guys.
See?
This is what's happening to me.
Why can't I get through?
I don't care.
Eh?
Am I actually supposed to go through here?
Or...
Over...
Oh!
Wait!
Oh my god!
Oh!
I made it!
Can you see me?
Hold on.
Why can't I go through the...
The...
Why can't I go through the sign?
Wait.
I think I'm stuck.
I'm stuck, you guys!
Oh!
I was stuck in the middle of the air.
I'm gonna have it look at me actually.
So you can see what I'm doing.
Maybe.
I actually don't know if you'll be able to see me.
Okay.
Hold on.
No.
Please.
No!
Wait.
Maybe if I jump here?
There we go.
Okay.
Jump!
My oshi is illiterate.
Metal Gear Solid 2 Plants Chapter 1.
Respawn point is dynamic respawn.
3 times.
In a row.
To return here.
You can access Arsenal gear through a shell one.
Those settings in the next room interact to hide.
It's all your fault!
Okay.
Let's go.
Let's...
Ikimashou.
Hold on.
Oh!
My bad.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to do that.
Alright.
Look at this!
Can they open?
They can!
Oh.
Wait.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
Take a screenshot of me!
In the locker!
Can you see?
Oh.
Hi mom!
Must have been the wind.
How do I get out?
Wait.
Can...
If I jump, can you see my hand?
Oh.
You can't.
Ta-da!
Wait.
I'll do a different pose every time.
Ta-da!
Ta-dum!
Ta-dum...
How do I...
Wait.
Hold on.
Let's go, silly!
Come on.
Let's keep going.
We got to...
Get the nerd?
Beep-boop-bop!
La la la!
How do you do?
Hacking, hacking, hacking, did you just say nerd?
Let's go.
Where's this?
Oh, I think I turned the world sound off.
There we go.
Oh my god, there's actually ambience, thank goodness.
Wait.
I'm gonna fix the camera just a little bit.
Um...
Oh, maybe I shouldn't have it just looking at me the whole time.
Sorry.
It's been a long time since I've used a VR chat, so...
It's uh...
Hayden!
Thank you for the vibe, give the thank you!
Uh, one second.
Kinda want it like over my shoulder, right?
So that we can walk through this together.
So you can take my hand.
Just kidding, you can't grab it.
I'm a ghost!
Okay.
This way.
Here we go.
Whoa!
Oh, this is a work in progress.
April 4th, 2024.
This is what it says here.
So that, remember when I said I saw it pretty recently?
That's when I saw it.
Incorrect locker sound in B1 filtration chamber number 2.
Performance improvements try to reduce a ram by ram.
Some doors and warehouse have a wrong way door asset.
Improved world lighting.
Wow!
Fix seagulls flying.
Add sound to various areas.
Add more ciphers.
No, no, no, no.
I'm trying to read it, but my chat is right here.
And the...
So it's kind of like...
More death triggers.
Respawn if you get stuck.
Teleport system.
And mirrors, I guess.
For some reason, people in VR chat, they...
I can't look at you unless I turn around.
They love mirrors.
I don't know why.
But like, I've been told by people that do a lot of VR chat that sometimes people will just sit in a room for hours.
And just look at themselves in the mirror.
Isn't that kind of crazy?
Let's keep going.
Thank you!
Oh god.
Why did I do that?
Anyway.
Settings.
Background music.
Oh yeah, let's do that.
Oh.
I think it's just the ambience.
Okay, nevermind.
Particles.
I don't see any.
Or dance in front of them.
Maybe.
Real...
What does that say?
What does this one say?
Real...
Hime.
Time lights.
Just kidding.
I don't need you.
Let's keep going.
The nerd!
Now here's where we really nerded out.
Okay, guys.
I'm trying to get a good angle for you.
Oh my god!
Mom, I'm on the nerd!
I'm on the nerd!
Woohoo!
Oh!
Woah!
Where did I go?
Help me!
Help!
Did she just say nerd?
La la la la la.
This is me spreading lies on the internet.
Can I actually interact with it?
No, it doesn't seem to be the case.
Oh, no worries.
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
We're gonna go upstairs!
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Here we go.
Beep!
Ah!
Okay.
Here we go!
Strut a roof.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
It says strut a roof, but it doesn't show it for you guys.
That's kinda sad.
It showed it just like how it looks in the game.
Wow!
It's beautiful!
Turn around!
Look at that!
Oh!
Where did I go?
Where did the sun go?
Oh!
Oh, I...
You can see it.
I can't see it though for some reason.
Wow!
Oh!
Oopsie.
I accidentally went back downstairs.
Mother base?
It really looks like a mother base, doesn't it?
Hold on.
My fault.
We gotta go back up.
I didn't know it was an insta-teleport.
Okay, here we go.
We'll go around.
Wow!
We're back!
Oh my gosh!
It looks so beautiful!
Big shell!
Whoa!
And the water and everything.
Wow!
There's even the bird poop!
Wait, you guys can't see it.
Hold on.
Where are you?
There you are.
Look at the bird poop!
Hold on.
Oh, let me turn off auto-level.
Oh!
Get a picture of me with the bird poop!
Tease.
Ahem.
Ah-ah-ahem.
Moe.
Kyong!
Tease.
Oh!
I almost fell over.
Tease.
My apple.
How does it do that?
Wowee, quite a show, huh?
Anyway.
So beautiful.
That's where Emma died.
Well, that's not where Emma dies, but this is where Emma will die.
Cool.
Shall we continue onward?
I can see stuff over there.
Oh, there's some ciphers over there.
And, oh wait, hold on.
I forgot to do something.
I forgot to do the most important thing.
Gotta put you back a little bit, though.
I forgot to Looney Tunes myself on the bird poop.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay,
that was good.
That was a good one, wasn't it?
Okay.
How do I want you guys to follow me again?
We'll just have you follow me.
Let me follow my back again, okay?
Alright, returning.
We're going this way.
There's more bird poop!
There's more of it, right there!
And there should be some more over here!
More bird poop!
Now let's get inside, but we can't crawl through there.
The door is wide open for us for easy access.
But can you guys see through here?
You can see, like...
You can see, like, the pipes over there.
And stuff.
It's so cool, right?
This is how MGS4 should have ended?
What do you mean?
Can you skateboard around in VR?
Scuff Word!
Scuff Word, if you're listening!
Oh my gosh, the funniest thing!
Okay, hold on.
So, when I was preparing for this stream, I asked Scuff Word.
Scuff Word is the person that made the model.
So, thank you, Scuff Word!
Oh, you're here!
I have been summoned!
Scuff Word, if you want to put sunglasses.
If you want to give me some cool shades.
But no pressure, you know?
But, anyway.
Last night, I messaged Scuff Word.
I was just like, Hey, is it possible that I could use this model in VRChat for my stream?
I saw that you made it, and it's so cute!
And they were like, yeah!
And then...
Oh, that made me headset.
They uploaded it for me.
I was so happy.
It was so nice.
Because otherwise, I would have had to redownload Unity and do all that funny stuff.
But...
They were like, oh, I'll upload it for you.
And then, you can just grab it from my private world.
And I was like, cool!
And I joined...
Let me show you how I looked.
Oh, don't look at me.
Oh!
Did you hear that?
Since I didn't have an avatar...
This is the only one I could find.
Well, not the only one.
But this is...
Maybe the best one I could find.
I'm a rat!
Look at me!
I'm a rat, everybody!
But...
Because...
The model...
Or the avatar...
I think it's a little weird on VRChat.
Even if you change an avatar to public...
It doesn't show up publicly for everybody immediately.
And so...
When they...
When they made it public...
I had to wait.
But...
I was like, oh no.
I don't want you to have to like...
Wait on...
I don't want...
Because they would have to invite me back to their private world.
I was like, I don't want you to have to be like...
Oh, I'm busy.
I can't invite you back to my private world right before my stream.
So I was like, you know what I'll do?
I will sit in your private world.
All night.
I left VRChat.
Pin?
Nice pin.
What are you talking about?
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to pin it.
Sorry.
Unpin.
I'm just clapping my hands everywhere.
Sorry.
You had your five seconds of fame.
Okay.
I don't even know.
Sorry.
Who it was.
But anyway, so I stayed in.
I stayed in VRChat the whole night and like just as this tiny little rat sitting in this void world just next to the thing that would allow me to change into this avatar.
I thought it was really silly because I woke up and I got on my computer and I tested it out.
And I was just like, oh, hey, I can use the model now.
And yeah, it was really silly.
So anyway, so that's why the controllers were dead.
No, no, no, no.
I was on.
I was on desktop.
My VR stuff hadn't even been hooked up yet.
So sorry that I pinned you and unpinned you.
You probably were so excited.
You were like, what does it mean?
Why was I pinned?
And then I took it all away from you.
I wiped out your pin.
Anyway, let's keep going.
Wait, what time is it?
Okay.
I still have an hour before my meeting.
My very real meeting.
We're going to strut a pump room.
The music!
And oh, wait, these are not the Zone of the Enders boxes.
Where are those ones?
Oh, no, that's okay.
Yes, I know where we are.
There it is!
Hold on.
I'm going to be really sneaky.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm going to crouch down a little bit.
Here.
Even look at me.
Look at me.
Except watch me be...
Shh.
Okay.
I'm going to be sneaky.
Why is my butt in the air like that?
Wait.
Don't look.
I'm going to hack.
But sneaky.
Wait, can I sit here?
No.
I'm sneaky.
I'm sneaking around.
I'm glad that when I...
Where are you?
Oh, you're looking.
Here we go.
When you guys saw my thumbnail, you were like, wow, it's very Bigfoot-esque.
You guys got what I was going for.
Nice.
Let's keep going.
This way.
Oh, is the music okay for you guys?
Do you want me to turn it up a little bit?
What was that noise?
What noise?
Okay.
We're going to go to the other side.
Why is it so...
This is not where we came from, but let's try it out.
Strut a roof.
I think it's just the other side.
Yeah, it's just the other side.
Okay.
Nevermind.
It must have been the wind.
Whoa.
Let's go through here.
Oh, this is where you crawl through the pipes and stuff to get out.
Let's get to the bomb!
What was that noise?
Can I get in here?
Uh oh, wait, I don't want to get stuck in here though.
Uh oh, wait a minute.
Was this a bad idea?
Uh oh, you guys?
Uh oh, wait a second.
Wait a second, I think we might be stuck.
Uh oh, wait a minute.
Maybe through here?
Uh oh.
Uh oh, can I slip through here?
Oh, I hear it!
You see the bomb?
Wait, is that the bomb?
Or is that just a pole?
I hear it though, do you guys hear it?
You... you...
You...
You guys, I'm stuck!
I'm stuck in here!
For real!
Um...
Uh... what do I do?
Respawn.
Oh, there we go!
Nice!
I want to see if we can get to it.
Oop.
Sorry if I'm going a little fast.
Oh, nice!
I actually don't remember where it's at.
There it is!
I see it, I see it, I see it, I see it!
Ahem.
Mint's back.
Don't look!
Okay.
This is very serious business.
I will defuse this bomb.
Oh wait, what just happened?
Oh wait, I changed my chat on accident, hold on.
What just happened?
I don't know.
Thank you though.
Whatever.
I don't know why I'm saying thank you.
Diffused!
Good job!
Okay.
I don't know how to get out of here again.
So, uh...
You're gonna follow me!
You're just gonna follow me!
I'll take the lead, okay?
Oh!
Oh no!
I almost had it!
Okay, nice, nice.
Haha!
I mean...
Let's keep going.
We're doomed!
What are you talking about?
I totally blew that out.
Are these more lockers?
What?
Oh, sorry.
It has...
Konami eyes!
They're even in here!
Wait a second.
Um...
Can I get a...
Can I get a certain achievement?
Being in there?
Um...
Uh...
Anybody...
Anybody want to get the, um...
The snake beater?
Achievement...
Anybody...
Okay.
It's okay.
I'll take the sacrifice.
Good night!
What do you...
What do you mean, ouch?
No, I'm only doing really pleasurable things in here.
Hoo-wee!
I just flew in and boy...
Are my arms tired!
Okay, um...
I think I used that joke one too many times today.
Maybe.
Uh...
Wait.
One second.
Alright.
Follow me!
Oh no, we went this way.
We want to go...
There, through the exit over here.
Right here.
A-B connecting bridge.
Wow...
Wee!
Wow!
So beautiful!
Box time!
Let's keep going.
Sorry if you're going through the walls sometimes.
Look, you can see the water!
Woah!
Don't fall out.
Don't fall...
What if I do fall though?
What if I do fall?
Oops, my bad.
Here we go!
Wait.
Huh!
Right,
what's wrong?
Right!
Wait, could you...
Could you see that?
Or did you only see the...
No, you only saw it.
You only heard it, probably.
It actually showed the whole menu.
That was so good!
It showed the whole menu and everything.
It was just like...
It showed like the...
Sorry, I keep forgetting you guys were on this side.
It showed the whole, like, you die menu and everything.
What just happened?
Don't worry about it.
It's just ghost things, you know?
Just ghost things.
Okay.
Um...
This way.
I'm trying to figure out how I want the camera to go.
There we go.
Oh!
Wait!
You must see!
Look!
Look, look, look!
Oh my god!
No!
Let's go!
It's trying to be a transformer room.
It's kind of spooky, isn't it?
It's kind of spooky!
Wait, I'm scared!
Wait, but there's no one here.
But me!
I'm a ghost!
I'm haunting this place.
Okay, let's go.
Whoa, there's so much blood on the ground!
Wowee.
Okay, let's go.
Do you think he'll be here?
Some winks!
I hear another one.
Dracula?
No.
Oh yeah.
Okay, it's your turn.
It's your turn to go in.
Listen here.
Listen here, nerd.
Yeah, nerd.
I'm putting you...
I'm putting you in the closet.
I mean, the locker where you belong.
And you never come back out.
You hear me?
Nerd!
Was that enough for you?
Was that enough time?
Was that all you needed?
I feel like you don't need that much time.
Not for you, at least.
What else is in here?
Nothing.
Nothing here.
Put me back in.
What do you think this is?
The b-ball court?
No, you're getting benched.
Okay.
One second.
Follow me.
There's so much blood in here.
I sure hope some guys that are...
some...
I sure hope some guys named...
I don't even know their name.
Some guys that are, you know...
allies of this ship.
I sure hope they don't come in here.
They're definitely allies.
You know?
I sure hope they don't come in here.
Hold on, I gotta actually rearrange some stuff because my...
My setup is all weird.
Okay.
Seal Team 10.
Yeah.
Sure hope not.
That would be really...
I sure hope...
I sure hope some guy...
doesn't sit here and smoke at all.
That would be like...
really weird.
Oh my god.
I'm freaking out a little bit.
I sure hope some guy doesn't sit here and take a nap.
My legs are getting jelly because I'm nervous.
Because I'm nervous.
Can someone...
Photoshop...
Pushkin right here?
Right there.
Actually, in my arms.
Where is my computer at?
Oh, here.
Thank you!
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
I can't read.
I'm covered in cords.
One second.
Where's my mouse?
Oh, there it is.
Thanks!
I don't know actually which ones are showing up.
But thank you.
Alright.
Let's go.
I'll be back for you.
There's a nerd?
And there's a nerd.
Let's keep going this way.
Jittery physics.
Oh!
There was no other door in here, was there?
Sorry, I forgot.
This one.
Oh wait!
We have to go down here.
Not bad.
Embrace the nerd.
Oh wait, this way.
There we go.
We're on BC connecting bridge.
I wanna find...
This is gonna sound so bad.
Oh, look at that!
Wait, is this where he goes...
It's a dud!
Isn't this where Fortune destroys the bridge and he goes...
A dud!
Did you say no?
Absolutely.
Well, Fortune was here, right?
Yeah, I think she was on the other side.
What's it like in VR?
Oh my god, it smells so good.
I bet that's Fortune's smell.
I bet Fortune's making that smell.
Her pheromones.
For me.
Fortune.
Anyway, I wanna find...
Oops, sorry.
I didn't mean to put you guys in the wall.
My goal, even though I only have...
Well, I have one hour.
I wanna find...
This is gonna sound so bad, but I wanna find where Emma gets shot.
Because it's one of my favorite shots in the game.
Well, not the...
Not like...
Viewing shot.
Well, she doesn't get shot.
She gets stabbed.
We didn't shoot her.
You know what I mean?
Oh my god, wait!
It's the bathroom!
Oh my god!
You can even see my thingy!
This is how I'm viewing...
What I'm doing for you guys.
Oh say...
Can you see...
By the...
Dazzling...
Lights...
God bless America.
Whoa!
Why is...
Wait a second.
Why is she in the girl's bathroom?
Why is she on every...
Star in the girl's bathroom?
Also guys...
I gotta go to the little ghost's room.
One moment.
Can I actually use the toilet?
No.
Stall's taken!
Wonder who's in the men's room?
Let's check it out!
You and me.
Gonna lift you up just a little bit.
Ok.
Ok, you ready?
Follow me Oh wait!
Oh wait.
I use the bathroom, you guys.
I have to...
Wait hold on.
Sorry.
I'm always trying to adjust it so it's not too invasive.
I have to...
I have to wash my hands.
Wash your hands dude.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
I'm working on it, okay?
Gosh.
Gotta get under my fingernails.
Scrub-a-dub-a-dub.
What songs did they say that you can sing?
Four.
Didn't flush the toilet?
It's automatic.
Gosh.
I hear a bomb?
It's just a bomb up there.
Don't worry about it.
It's decorative.
Happy birthday.
Snake Eater?
What a thrill.
With darkness and silence through the night.
I'm searching and I'll melt into you.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
Oh wait, hold on.
Okay, let's go now.
To the men's room.
I'm not supposed to be in there.
Here we go.
What?
There's only two stalls?
Why is there only two?
How much you wanna bet she's in there?
Oh, there she is.
Where she is?
There she is!
Oh, it's the urinals.
Where do you flush?
How do you flush it?
It's automatic?
Are you sure?
Isn't...
There's no water that comes through at all?
So it just stinks like pee all the time?
I don't know.
There is water.
Oh, okay.
Well, anyway.
Let's get out of here.
It stinks.
Let's go down here.
This is the kitchen, right?
Yeah!
Oh!
The orange!
Can I get in?
Can I grab it?
No, I can't interact.
No!
Oh my gosh, the orange!
The orange!
Just hold on.
I can still blend in though.
I can still blend in.
Just a box.
Too short to use the urinal.
Shut the hell up!
Just a box.
Nobody would know.
How would they know?
The Minto.
It's 9.13.
We got to go go go.
We got to go find e-e and rescue her.
But also, If they wanted me to go faster they shouldn't put this distracting images on the wall.
I feel like this could be edited into a meme, you know?
If I'm just like... hold on...
If I'm just like...
You know?
You could put a picture here.
Boo-ba.
Okay, let's keep going.
There's also... this is where...
That's over... oh wait, sorry, you can't see it.
Over there...
Let me see if my controllers...
My controllers are not...
so great, but...
mmm...
I can't believe that they said that they were charged when they were at 0%.
That's where...
That's where the bomb guy was.
Look at all these...
You see her?
Sheesh.
Stillman, yeah, yeah.
There's even watermelons here.
Can you go in here?
Oh wait, this isn't... oh, he was in there.
That's right.
I thought I got the wrong door.
Can we go inside?
Oh, we can!
Not much in here.
It's like this, it looks like you're spying on me.
Stop, you creep.
I love my gross ojisan, Oshi.
She is such a freak, and we love her for that.
I'm leaving!
You guys don't understand me.
I think this is the... yeah, this is the right way.
Now we're on CD connecting bridge.
Does anyone understand you?
I don't know.
No one understands me.
No one gets me.
We gotta go.
Run, run, run.
What's over here?
Oh, this goes down.
Wait, do these fall?
Oh god.
They do!
They fall, they fall, they fall!
Oh my god.
How are you guys feeling?
Are you guys motion sick at all?
Are you guys feeling okay?
Am I moving too fast?
Am I moving too quickly?
Are we alright?
All good?
Not a bit?
I'm good?
It's perfect?
I'm not motion sick?
I'm just sick of you?
I'M SICK OF YOU!
Okay.
I'm drunk right now.
Don't drink and watch streams.
Alright, let's go through here.
Oh!
Surveillance camera!
Oh my gosh, look at it!
It's moving even!
Okay,
let's go through here.
Oh, it's dark.
Strut D, sediment pool.
Oh, I hate this area!
I HATE this area!
I hate this area.
Did I mention I hate this area?
Woah...
You can see in there, and like the...
There's like...
Hold on, let me see if I can show you guys.
You can see like...
Oh, sorry, auto levels.
You see like the reflections and stuff from the... I guess the steam?
From the water?
Or whatever the hell that is.
Thinks she likes this area.
NO!
You need to learn how to listen.
Don't drop us.
One second.
Okay, let's go.
Which way should I go though?
Actually, I don't remember.
There's this one, and then there's that one.
There's that one over there.
And then there's also the lower levels.
Oh no way, I don't remember which way to go.
The nerd is down there.
Nothing here.
But this is MGS fans dream come true, for real.
Love this for you.
I know, it's so fun!
Oh my god.
It's so awesome.
I don't remember this particular building.
I don't remember which way gets us to Emma.
This is...
Level 1.
I can't read.
What's this one?
You're an expert, Minto.
I'm not an expert with...
Oh!
Shell 1 to 2!
Wait, can we even get through here?
Or will it tell us no?
Yeah.
Um...
I think...
This is where we get the cell phone.
We have...
A bit of a problem.
Actually, now that I think about it...
There's areas all around here that look like where...
Wait a second.
I think actually over there.
That might be it.
Hold on, let me show you guys.
Cause it has the staircase.
Or the ladder.
Right there?
Right?
Is that it?
Maybe?
Sorry, my sleeves are so big.
That right there, right?
Pretty sure that's where we...
Where we went down from.
And then they cross...
They cross through here, right?
But at the same time...
Here, I'll show you the other side.
It looks the exact same.
So I'm not quite sure anymore.
Alright guys, I'm gonna have to jump.
But I'm gonna make this jump without you.
Okay?
I'll bring you over once it's safe.
Here, watch me from afar.
You can do it.
Alright kid.
I'll see you later.
On the other side.
We did it!
What, you think that I didn't do it?
Come on.
We did it.
Alright.
Now look at me.
Don't look at me.
I'll turn around.
It's really smoky here.
So we gotta be careful, okay?
Wait, actually...
How do I get over there?
Uh...
Hold on, I don't wanna fall off.
Okay.
Here we go.
I got it.
We're gonna jump through here.
Nice!
Run, run, run!
They fell through.
Don't get peed on.
I think we're safe from...
Do you guys... wait.
Can you see it?
Up there, the ship...
That's not...
That's not the ship that...
Solidus... not ship.
Oh my gosh.
The... Solidus doesn't use a plane though.
Or is it the Harrier?
I can't tell.
Is it?
It is the Harrier?
Yeah, it looks like the Harrier.
Oh my god!
It's Solidus' Harrier!
Wow!
So cool.
There's so many things in this game.
I mean, in this recreation, I guess.
Alright, we gotta jump down.
Okay.
Very good.
And then, I don't know if you guys...
Oh, you can see it.
Look, it says return to the...
Teleport, if you need to go back up.
Or if you wanna go back up.
But not us!
I wonder if I drop from down there?
I wonder if we'll make it.
You think?
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, how am I supposed to get over there?
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god!
We made it!
You can get a better look of it from here too.
Hi Solidus!
I'm using my gunpowder like a good girl!
Parkour.
Teleport.
Stretch out perimeter.
Oh my gosh, you can see it even more from here!
Hi Solidus!
Wait, big shell?
Yeah, isn't this awesome?
Okay.
Oh geez.
You guys, uh...
This one's not looking so good.
Okay, I think I have to be very, very careful.
Sorry for the camera.
It doesn't look like that to me, only to you.
Okay, here we go.
Onwards!
Uh...
Whoa, it's like really broken for you guys right now.
There we go.
Ahem.
Hug the wall.
Oh, and this also is if you want to return.
Nice!
Okay.
We're going up.
Shell 2!
Hi Shell 2!
Wait, where is, um...
Where do we see...
Fat Man at?
I can't remember.
Gosh, I can't wait to play MGS2.
Beep beep!
What do you mean beep beep?
What do you mean?
Hold on.
I also gotta fix my camera stuff again real quick.
Sorry guys.
I keep turning and since my VR stuff is is on a cord, right now it's a little difficult to...
It's a little...
I keep turning and so it makes it harder to move around.
Beep beep!
What do you mean beep beep?
We need the access card.
Put you up even.
Maybe it's too high up.
Put you back a little bit.
There we go.
This is better, right?
Okay.
If I... Okay, wait.
I have a second.
Not a second.
I have a...
I have an idea.
What if because you guys are the camera, I just walk backwards and then you guys tell me what's in there.
What is it?
What do you see?
What's in there?
Do you see anything?
Do you have a second?
It's darkness.
It's a black hole.
It's the void.
I guess...
I guess it's a good thing we can't go in there.
If it's all just darkness.
Oh, geez.
Um...
Hold on one second.
Hmm...
Let's just keep going.
I think I see fortune.
Don't lie to me.
Don't get my hopes up.
Shell two core.
One floor.
First floor.
Air purification room.
Oh my gosh.
Also, you guys can't really see it, but the floors are so shiny.
Wait!
The president!
I'm coming for you, Mr. President!
Oh, he's not.
He's...
You guys, he's already long gone.
He's dead dead.
High voltage.
He's...
This is where it comes through.
Right here.
You're a man?
No, I'm a mint.
...
Let's keep going this way.
And this...
This I would like to fondly call Trauma Central.
I'm going to do a reenactment.
I'm going to do a reenactment of...
of trying to get Emma out of this location.
No, Emma, please!
Get up, Emma!
Just get up!
There she is!
...
Oh my god!
I'm going to have to drag Emma!
I'm going to have to drag her!
...
Okay.
They're dead.
Come on, Emma!
Come on!
...
Oh my god, there's more!
There's too many!
Emma, I'm sorry!
I gotta get out of here!
...
Snake!
Please!
I need your help!
Snake!
I'm going offline!
Snaaaaaaake!
End scene.
Did you guys like that?
Thank you.
I'm trapped.
Oh, wait.
Thank you.
That's so cute, I can't bear it.
Stop it!
Stop it.
Okay, let's keep going.
Oh, no, no, no, I just messed up my camera.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, like so.
Cinema.
Okay, we'll just go this way.
Then we get to the elevator over here and we can go see...
Wait a second, though.
So we take Emma...
Emma back through there.
Let's see what happens if we go downstairs, though.
Call elevator.
Oh, nice.
Okay, here we go.
B... B1.
It's peak.
Are there any bugs down here?
Oh, they didn't include the bugs!
There's no bugs, actually.
Beep, boop, bop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Babycore, thanks for the gift.
Thank you.
Whoa!
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, how do I swim?
Is there a way to go down?
Oh, gosh, you guys.
I don't know if we can go through here.
Okay, hold on.
How do I go down?
Uh...
We managed to avoid drowning.
Oh, bonk.
Come on.
Duck, duck, duck, duck, duck, duck.
I don't think we can go.
Press the left stick down to deser...
Blub, blub, blub, blub, blub, blub.
Call the colonel.
Aw, guys, I tried.
Unless, like, it's jump for some reason.
Oh, wait.
I was in there.
You saw, right?
Okay, hold on.
Take it.
Okay,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
Oh, man.
Ghosts.
Ghosts just float.
Apparently.
I have to use my own arm?
I do.
Ew.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no!
Blub blub blub blub blub blub.
No!
Ah!
RMIT, blub blub blub blub blub.
Card off!
Blub blub blub bluv adulh!
Let's get out of here.
Grace, please help!
He's coming.
Okay, wait.
So, we take... Aw, that's kind of disappointing though.
I thought for sure we would be able to go see the room where EE is at.
Wait, this way is more comfortable.
Okay, let's go inside.
I hope you guys don't mind just seeing my back the whole time.
I figured it's kind of like...
We're on the journey together, you know what I mean?
You're just following behind me.
Kind of deal, you know?
Cold drinks?
I'm throwing my money in there.
Okay.
Very good.
It's fine.
Okay, I'm glad.
And then there's some security cameras in here.
Or not.
Never mind.
Wow, now I'm a liar.
So, we bring her back.
Back through here.
Conscious or unconscious.
So, this is where we came from.
And then we were like...
Then we were like...
Wait, where do we go from here?
All I remember is...
Is it down... No, it's not down there.
How do we get to the...
How do we get down there?
I only have 30 minutes left.
What do I do?
Strut L.
Where's Strut L?
Gosh, I wish I had a map.
The door that leads down to Oil Fence is left maybe.
No, this is the one that...
That went boop-boop.
Unless we can't get down there.
Let's see.
Strut on the right.
Oh, you're right!
Right here.
And here?
Strut L Sewage Treatment Facility.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
I remember this!
Uh-oh, I might accidentally pin a comment.
Sorry.
I'm trying to open this up.
My chat is right here, so that's why.
Where am I?
Where is this place?
Huh?
Oh, you guys can see the outside world, but I can't.
Hmm?
Oh, the hatch!
There it is!
Oh, it looks really funky.
Oh, my...
Oh!
What?
There's a gun!
Oh, my God.
There's the sniper!
Oh, this is so funny!
Oh, my God.
Oh!
It's a little heavy.
My bad.
And then we listen over here, and it's Johnny pooping himself, and then if I shoot over here, there's Snake!
Wait, hold on, I want you guys to see.
Oh, my bad.
One second.
Hmm.
How can I get you...
the full view?
Will you guys protect me?
If I, um...
Okay.
You guys, I'm giving you the gun.
If I can pick it up.
Wait.
Hold on.
There we go.
I'm giving you guys the gun.
And you have to shoot down anything that tries to attack me while I go all the way over to the other side.
Okay?
It's your response.
It's your duty.
Take it.
I'll see you later.
Soldier.
Oh!
I almost fell in.
Where are the stars in the skies up above?
And think what am I made of?
Am I full of sorrow?
Am I hurt when pained?
Or am I filled with... Right.
What's wrong?
Right!
You guys are supposed to protect me!
You guys are supposed to... You guys are supposed to protect me!
What happened?
Okay.
I got one more shot.
I'm believing in you.
Okay.
Um...
What am I made of?
Am I full... Sorry if I get the lyrics wrong by the way.
I can't really remember.
You know what?
I'm gonna go around.
Oh my god!
Johnny!
Wait.
No.
He's at the next one.
Just kidding.
Haha.
You thought...
Wait.
You thought there was Johnny.
Nope.
I was just kidding.
Hi mom!
Wow.
It's so beautiful from here.
Actually I kinda wish the sky was a little bit more orange.
It's so nice over here.
Wish you were here!
Or am I filled with love?
I walk down the street.
Oh.
Oh!
Wait!
Wait a second.
There's actually something here.
There's like a headset here.
Oh my god.
It reeks!
Wait.
I'm not lying.
There's actually like a... like a... what's the word?
Like a pair of headphones.
A pair of headphones.
Can I pick them up?
Doesn't look like it.
Oh my god.
Johnny!
Johnny Akiba!
Johnny Akiba Sasaki!
What are you doing here?
Oh my god!
Not on my stream!
Hi guys!
Hello!
Can you see me?
Can you see me waving at you?
Wow!
It's so beautiful!
Hey guys!
Don't forget to shoot it!
If anything comes and gets me!
Don't forget to shoot!
I sure hope no bisexuals come out of the water!
You took the ammo with you.
No I didn't.
I'm looking in the water.
It looks pretty clear.
I sure hope!
That there's no bisexuals in the water!
Oh no!
Oh god!
Oh!
Right!
What's wrong?
Do you guys want to go on Emma's simulator?
Follow me!
Like I said, it's really pretty.
Alright, here we go.
You can see the whole place from here.
Oh!
Don't fall!
We can take it slow.
I'll show you the headphones that were on the other side and everything.
Right!
What's wrong?
Uh...
Anyway...
It's harder than it looks, okay guys?
It's harder...
It's harder than it looks, okay?
It takes more balance than you'd realize.
Okay.
Then you come around here and it's just the vast, vast ocean.
It's just all ocean.
It's nothing much else.
But I love the ocean.
So I really like this.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
Watch your step now.
Watch your step.
Okay.
Good.
We're going.
We're running.
And jump!
Okay.
See him?
See right there?
It's a pair of headphones.
But I can't pick them up for some reason.
Oh wait!
Listen!
A girl?
What are you doing here?
It's my choice, thank you very much.
Oh.
You're not gonna shoot me.
No.
Why not?
Stay away from good looking women when you're fighting.
Otherwise you'll get hit with diarrhea.
One of the few things I learned from Shadow Moses.
What are you talking about?
Ancient history.
Don't worry about it.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
But does this mean you're letting me go?
Well, you could have found a nicer way to say that.
But sure.
Better hurry.
Thanks.
Don't mention it.
Just run like a...
Oh no, my stomach.
Not again.
This place is about to sink.
Just get out fast, okay?
Oh god.
What?
What's your name?
Don't have one.
Okay, fine.
It's Johnny.
Johnny!
I'm not gonna make it.
Hey, if we run into each other again...
What a weird guy.
Oh!
Oh my god!
That was so fun!
Did you guys hear that?
I didn't...
I guess I just didn't...
I didn't lean down far enough before.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
That was so awesome.
The whole thing.
Perfect.
I'm so glad that we came back then.
Okay, careful, careful.
I wish up there though you could...
Oh wait, hold on.
I wish up there you could see...
Wait, you could see a little cypher going by!
It's so cute!
Um...
Wait, hold on.
I'll be very careful to show you.
Oh wait, no, you're all the way out in the ocean.
I can't grab you.
Hold on, let me go back upstairs.
Gimme.
Oh wait.
There we go.
You see it?
You see it flying around up there?
Cypher!
Oh, it's gone now.
Chat, is the streamer about to cry because she loves MGS2 so much?
Stop it!
Stop!
Why you gotta...
Why you gotta call me out like that?
Stop calling me out.
Hmm...
Okay.
Let's keep going.
Hold on, let me adjust myself as well.
There we go.
And you.
I think that should be good.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go to where she died.
But I also wanna show you...
Wait, can I?
Oh yeah, I can grab you from there.
Okay, good, good, good.
This is where she dies.
Look how beautiful!
Hold on.
Have to be very careful.
Come here.
Wow!
It's so pretty!
It's actually so relaxing here.
Haha.
It's so relaxing.
Any vamp easter eggs?
I don't think so.
I don't see anything.
There's not even blood here.
It's not even blood.
I think actually she dies down a little bit.
Oops, sorry.
I can't grab you.
Come on.
I kept trying to grab you but I can't for some reason.
Oh, there we go.
I think actually she dies right before it, right?
Like right here.
But there's still no blood or anything.
I say die, I mean get stabbed.
When she gets attacked.
So that means the next location should be...
Where she actually dies.
Right?
What time is it?
Oh, I have 10 minutes!
Oh gosh, you guys.
Strut E, Parcel Room 1F.
Here.
Shoop.
And we go through here.
And here.
Oh, there's the Zone of the Enders boxes!
What's up here?
Oh, this is where the boxes are.
Just kidding.
Actually, I have no idea where we are now.
Hahaha.
Ahhh!
Can I get up there?
I don't think so.
There it goes!
Wee!
Well, guys...
Actually, I kind of want to end off in the nice sunset area, if that's okay.
So we'll go back outside.
We'll go back to the We'll go back to the dead area.
There we go.
Yay!
Thank you guys for letting me indulge in my my Metal Gear brand ride a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Thanks for the weird tour!
Have fun at Off-Kite in Japan!
Thank you!
Thank you for the off-kite!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to unplug my other...
I'm going to unplug my things now because...
Thank you!
This is pretty good!
Yeah!
I had so much fun!
I hope you guys did too.
I know that maybe it was...
If you don't know Metal Gear, maybe it was kind of whatever.
But it was really cool.
Just seeing... and then up there!
Up right above is a snake!
Plissken!
It's right there!
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you!
Um...
But yeah.
So I'll be going to Off-Kite this weekend!
And then right from after Off-Kite I'll be going to Japan!
But I will be streaming in Japan as much as I can.
Matara and I will be doing every other day.
So she streams one day and then I stream the next day and then she streams the next day.
You know.
Whatever.
Stream with so much fun!
Have fun at Off-Kite!
Thank you!
Thank you for the tour of the facilities!
Can't wait to see when you come back!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
I'll miss you guys!
Because I won't be able to see you guys so much since I'll be in Japan but we'll have so many stories and so many things to tell you about.
So I'm very excited for that as well.
And also whatever we're cooking while we're there.
One wonder.
I wonder what that could be.
And then of course thank you Scuffford for making this fun low-poly model for me.
And um...
Yeah.
I didn't expect to take so much time here at the Big Shell but it was fine.
We went to McDonald's.
We went to that.
Rental... wait.
It was like maid cafe, rental girl cafe.
Fake me!
Thanks for the Uncle Super!
Thank you!
And um...
Yeah.
So you guys take care of yourself while I'm gone as well.
I'm gonna move you downwards a little to my level.
And um... yeah.
Looking forward to it!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Now I actually have to get to my meeting in 10 minutes.
That is a legit and real meeting.
I... I...
I...
Where are you guys?
I'm back!
Don't worry!
My very real...
My very real meeting that I have to go to.
That is not fake meeting.
It's real.
It's real and I remember when it is.
It's...
in 7 minutes.
Enjoy Aftaya in Japan.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
And um...
Um...
Um... I don't know what else to say.
Be good wisps.
Okay?
Be good wisps while I'm gone since I won't see you.
As much.
But I will still be seeing you.
Just not as much.
And um...
Thank you!
I'm a...
I'm a simp.
And um...
I don't know what else to say.
Sorry.
This is weird.
I don't know how to end these kinds of things because I'm like so...
Wiggly, wiggly, wiggly.
So um...
Uh... Can you end the stream that way?
You got it!
There we go.
Bye everyone!
Bye bye!
See you when I get back!
Or if I'm... Or if I say that off-guide...
See you there!
Bye bye!
Boodoodoo!
Doodoodoo!
Boodoodoodoo!
Boodoodoo!
Wait.
Do you guys want to watch me fall?
Boodoodoo!
Right, what's wrong?
Right, right!